[Music]
when the ground shakes it's probably
just an earthquake well 99% of the time
but that other 1% means that there is an
underground Subterranean monster on the
lose here in this video we will take a
deep look into another older movie
monster that was first featured in 1990
with its last installment 4 years ago in
2020 these are the gra boids that was
first seen in the movie Tremors and then
later in the sequels we will detail out
in sequence their Origins the different
species their life cycle and their
biology so let's get to it so the
origins of graboids was revealed in its
sequel movie Tremor Spot 2 This movie
shows a fossilized graboid spite dating
back to the prean era suggesting that
they have existed for at least 500
million years and that makes them the
oldest living life form on the planet or
at least a surviving species of a very
ancient animal genus however in tros the
series there is a difference in its
dating with the Sci-Fi channel
suggesting it might be from the devonian
period but not ruling out
extraterrestrial Origins despite their
wormlike appearance tremis 3 refers to
them as desert reptilians which seems
very wrong in so many ways while its
promotional material classifies them as
calop pods due to their intelligence
their beaks and tentacles which seems
more correct in any case they are the
oldest Survivor species on Earth out
living every other species except for
the hor shoe crab as of present with the
most recent 2020 movie Tremor shrier
Island the graboids are more widespread
on Earth as originally thought so they
are a total of four species the first
one being the original American species
which was discovered in Perfection
Valley in the middle of the suera Nevada
mountain range in the US the second is
the African species that are more
powerful and can jump out of the surface
for an ambush attack these are set to
exist in South Africa
the third species is an Arctic grabo
that are found in Northern Canadian
provinces and can borrow under the snow
the fourth species is a product of
artificial breeding and can survive
swimming in the ocean these adopt the
oceanic species well all these four
species are related to each other while
having certain different traits that
makes them unique they also have slight
changes in their life cycle a topic
which we shall discuss and dive into
right now so while the tro movies St
that there are only four stages a life
cycle for graboid we have discovered
there are actually five or six life
cycle stages in its species life the
first one is the dominex which are the
first stage in the life cycle these are
hot encased shells that can survive
being dominant on the ground for
centuries on end all the species have
these as their starting stage even
though the outer shell can become
fossilized due to the long Domin stage
the inner Yol is unaffected and can
remain in a viable state for all those
hundreds of years the second phase are
the juvenile dirt dragons which are also
known as the tulong or the shooters and
the baby graboids and they represent the
initial phase in the graboid life cycle
after the egg emerging right after the
hatching of the eggs these shooters are
compact enough to LEAP out of the ground
earning them their nickname however this
stage is brief as they quickly mature
into the full-fledged graboids some
might say that the shooter stage is a
transient or a miniature phase in the
overall grab life cycle but it is clear
that the stage comes first and then we
get to the bigger and more well known
phase then comes the mature grabo which
is the sole creature to feature in all
the films and the 2003 TV series with
four known species found in North
America and Africa in all these variants
the grabo represents the midstage in the
creatur's life cycle in the prequel
movie Tremors 4 The Legend begins which
is set in the year 1889 before they
acquired the current name they were
actually called the dirt dragons while
this name is then later referred to
their juvenile baby forms the graboid
name was then coined by Walter Chang in
Perfection Valley in 1990 these are the
giant sandworm like creatures that swim
underground and they weigh around 10 to
20 tons and measure 20 to 30 ft long or
6 to 9
M the shers are the next stage they
emerge from the graboid initially being
one of the tongues of the giant creature
which then grow legs and evolve to
survive on the surface these serve as a
transitional stage resembling a pupa or
a nymph in the life cycle considered
potentially the most dangerous form due
to the fact that they reproduce rapidly
playing a crucial role in the life cycle
as they later evolve into the as
blasters and then lay the graboid eggs
they are asexual Focus solely on
reproduction by consuming ample food
leading to exponential growth in numbers
their reproduction involves detaching a
fetus from their stomach or Urus lining
then vomiting it out on the ground with
a distinctive screeching process the
newborn immediately stands and then
exhibits F signs of growth and become a
mature shrier in a short amount of time
time as for their body design they are
essentially just a beaky mouth with legs
and also an ability to detect prey items
by thermal imaging from a unique organ
situated above its
snout then we also have the African
Grabber so in Tris five blood lines what
seem to be the snake likee tongues of
the graboids actually became entities
known as Grabbers these are distinct
from the American graboids tongues in
that they are sentient and independent
parts of the African graboid species
these creatures can independently hunt
climb Rock surfaces and target areas
beyond the reach of the Subterranean
graboid not really the same as the
tongues of the American counterparts
these grabus might represent a distinct
animal species though suggesting a
symbiotic relationship with the African
graboid but they could also be the
African species version of the shriekers
which are never
seen then we have the as Blaster which
represents the final stage of the grabo
life cycle and are seen in all the
species they emerge when a mature shria
under goes further development and they
are distinguished from shriekers in that
they have rocket abilities for aerial
launching also Wings to Glide in the air
and the capacity to lay eggs their body
is longer and more slender than the
shrier with fin-like wings for control
gliding despite lacking apparent ears
they also possess hearing capabilities
similar to earlier graboid forms and
they also have the ability to see in the
thermal Spectrum just like the shriekers
the American ass blasters measure just
over 6 ft in length about 3 ft in height
and with a head and a jaw approximately
2 ft long the Arctic and the African ass
blasters are bigger and have a circular
mouth with rows of spiky teeth instead
of a beak then yeah these ass blasters
lay the graboid eggs and the life cycle
continues so let's talk a bit on their
morphology and the biology at least for
the worm like graboid before closing so
the graboid is a colossal wormlike
creature measuring about 10 m or 30 ft
or 33 ft in length and over 2 m or 6.5
ft in diameter at its wide this point
weighing between 10 to 20 tons it claims
the title of the largest L animal on
earth covered in a thick lettery carrus
the graboid turbular body is Adon with
twisting spines or spikes arranged in
irregular Rose creating rings around its
form with which it moves under the
ground its head has three part jaws and
tentacles resembling serpents which act
as hunting tongues it can sense
vibrations on the ground and has a very
fast learning curve making it one of the
most intelligent species as well its
inner body is composed of for a majority
part muscles under the thick leathery
hide so all the graboid variants which
include the graboids the shers the as
blasts and so on respire the nitrogen
oxygen atmosphere suggesting the
presence of lungs it also has an
enclosed circular system with reddish
orange blood implying a cardiopulmonary
system for at least oxygen transport
while little is known about their
nervous system all forms display signs
of sophisticated brains notably and
possibly approaching the intelligence
levels of mamalian predators like wolves
and lions their biggest organ system
though however is the digestive Canal
which might extend for at least 100 m
and has a large stomach that can store
an entire cow inside of it so that's it
for now we will continue this in another
graboid Evolution and species video in
the near future well if this one takes
off anyway that's that if you like this
video then check this other one as well
and do check out our channel for more
Monster videos like support and
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
one take care
fam